élections générales ont centrafrique j -
4 one en parle avec hochfeldois clé qui
était analyste politique spécialiste de
la politique africaine
bonsoir en fait doit clé qui était merci
de répondre à nos questions cette
information à ce soir le président
français emmanuel macron s'est entretenu
avec son homologue centrafricain faustin
archange touadéra il a ordonné le survol
de la centrafrique par des avions de
chasse pour je cite marqué la
condamnation par la france des
tentatives de déstabilisation c'est ce
qu'a indiqué l'elysée votre réaction à
cela je remercie de m'avoir des la
parole par rapport au communiqué du
président français il ya un peu d'ironie
vaut tard que jamais ce qu'on attendait
cela depuis la part de la france il faut
rappeler que c'est le partenaire
traditionnel et avec un trafic qui a un
accord de défense
nous avons vu la russie qui a été
retenue pour eddy la centrafrique
on l'a vu aussi le monde a parlé et on a
attendu aussi la déclaration de la
france et cette déclaration on peut dire
que ça va dans le bon sens de ne pas de
l'ingérence non pour des régimes on peut
pas dire que la france fait des les
gérances puisque comme je voulais dit yj
le rappelle encore il ya des à la france
elle peut partir centrafricain et ya un
accord des défenses qui est qui qui date
des années et donc c'est normal que la
france normalement c'est la force qui
devait être en première ligne pour aller
défendre la démocratie en centrafrique
et puis c'est dans les landes et la
déception des centrafricains
il se rend compte que la france était en
retrait il a fallu qu'il a réussi à
prendre le défend-il suivi de la date
pour que la france puisse se sortir du
silence et faire la déclaration des
droits sans le sou 300 instructeurs
militaires envoyés par moscou ces
derniers jours
pourquoi c'est en sciences en
centrafrique à la proche des élections
présidentielles on a vu notamment les
groupes rebelles
faire une fusion une coalition à la
proche de de cette échéance électorale
et s'il faut observer bielak la santé
qu'elle vous allez vous rendre compte
que ce sont les mains d'acteurs les
acteurs qui change de comptes par
rapport à des humeurs par rapport à le
pronostic sur vienne et s'il faut partir
de là que sont les mêmes acteurs
il va falloir aussi qu'on se pose la
question quelle est la lecture des
centres appliquer de la crise dans un
trafic déjà et on va voir que la crise
dans son trafic il descend en flammes
ont une autre une autre une autre
version de cela et la compétence est
avérée également à une autre approche de
cette crise et on va voir que dans tout
ça leur son trafic 1 il est laissé à
l'abandon
il va falloir qu'à un moment donné que
la comité international entend le centre
africain pour que les deux se joignent à
fait de trouver une solution durable
puisque la crise à tous durant son long
jeu véritablement de ce double autant le
rappelle un parce qu'à la présidentielle
il ya également les législatives
présidentielle pour laquelle est exclue
françois bozizé l'ancien président
président déchu et qui a donc
former des fusions avec des groupes
rebelles en face il ya un faustin
archange touadéra le président sortant
président en exercice quel est l'enjeu
véritablement de ce double scrutin à la
fois présidentiel et législatif
renouvelée des têtes déjà existante ce
sont des noms connus
françois bozizé faustin archange
touadéra effectivement sens des noms
connus et la classe politique en tire au
jour d'aujourd'hui ce sont toujours les
mêmes qui a occupé la scène
centrafricaine de pluie et la plus de 20
ans et à cela on va voir que avec un
démocratie qui s'est installée par par
l'élection de deux fausses et des
fausses terme archange touadéra qu est
ce ce critère de vars consolider cet
acquis démocratiques et c'est pour cela
que des voix s'élèvent aux filles de
part et d'autre on reconnais que c'est
lyon qui s'est passé dans des bonnes
conditions soient apaisées parce qu'au
jour d'aujourd'hui hier il yal essuyé
l'une des figures des dents dans la
centrafrique un peu partout il ya des
combats mais peut-on faire des élections
apaisées dans ces conditions la question
se pose et le para de de la corde
cartoon qui est en même temps la mini ce
cap en garantie la sécurité à tout aux
électeurs sans travail aux électeurs
tout comme aux candidats mais cela n'est
pas le cas jusqu'au bout jusqu'au jour
d'aujourd'hui et le centre africain pour
pouvoir passer ce cap pour pouvoir avoir
des représentants qu'ils puissent le
représenter comme il se doit
doit aller voter le 27 mai on se rend
compte que c'était trop court et trop qu
ea cela suppose aussi que l'on voit là
qui sont des élections de la clef des
élections repas 2 à 2 des problématiques
la sécurité des habitants
on voit qu'il n'ya pas la sécurité
encore sûr
sur l'ensemble du territoire et un fait
qui s'est produit aujourd'hui en
centrafrique à bangui mais il ya celui
de quelques coups de ce qui est pour
occasionner des vandales
si cela se produisait pour le 27 je
crois que ça va
il va décrédibiliser le scrutin
ça c'est la première des choses désert
des choses le pouvoir en place a
toujours mis en avant le respect de la
constitution
les vingt-sept c'est la date
constitutionnelle pour ces élections
mais nous avons vu aussi que dans
l'article 115 de la constitution qui met
on est vrai que lorsque en candidat se
retire il va falloir prendre tout au
tout le processus il ya le candidat
georges bokassa qui vient de retirer sa
candidature
et on entend aussi dire qu'il ya un
autre candidat qui viennent de lui
emboîter le pas donc la question se pose
lorsqu'on veut on veut résulté la
position il va pas il va pas il va
encore falloir prendre goût et lycéens
gook en reste leur position dans tout
dans tout son élément pour que et en
expliquant à la copier centrafricain
pour qu'elle puisse se calme et que ces
élections ou en lui et livia 6 et le 27
mai et vont avoir lu et leur voler leur
vote vont être prises en compte pour que
le candidat qui serait élu sur un
légitime et partout le peut on parler à
part des élections des mauvaises des
élections mais des élections qui sont et
tu sors pas si dans de bonnes conditions
ça c'est très important pour le retour
de la paix en centrafrique selon l'onu
la centrafrique est le deuxième pays le
plus pauvre du monde
est ce que cette crise risque d'enfoncer
un peu plus le pays dans le marasme
économique encore inéluctable ou huit
la centrafrique est pour pour 42
capitalisme oui et des crises à
répétition de piqûres ne peut que
fragiliser la centrafrique
il faut aussi rappeler que de cette
pauvreté y est qu'elle puisse du capital
humain
il va falloir
et de la comité et airs de savant au
revoir pas dire qu'il n'y a pas eu le
soutien d'amnesty international mais il
y aura plus ce soutien dans le sens de
nous écouter pour voir comment peut-on
faire ensemble
c'est très important d'écouter
centrafrique à pouvoir prendre un nouvel
élan et de sortir de deux sticks
décennale qui aime bien qui a duré des
décennies sans trafic
merci orphée de cycléa qui était d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste politique spécialiste
évidemment de la politique africaine